(uplifting music)
- [Jane Goodall] We're
all part of one community.
- Hi everyone.
I'm Jessica Nabongo coming to you
from the National Geographic headquarters
in Washington, D.C.
For over 130 years,
Nat Geo has used its
groundbreaking storytelling
to inspire the explorer
in everyone, including me.
In October 2019, I became
the first black woman
to visit every country in the world.
Travel has helped me
better understand the world
and my place in it.
But when traveling isn't possible,
Nat Geo helps us all
explore the furthest reaches
of the Earth and beyond.
Tonight I am happy to serve as your guide
as we embark on a musical
journey that will take us
from the woodlands of Norway
to the coast of California.
We have an incredible
Earth Day Eve lineup ahead
with uplifting musical
performances by some
of our favorite planet-loving
artists alongside shout-outs
from beloved National
Geographic Explorers.
The party continues afterwards
on Nat Geo's TikTok.
All of this as we count
down to Earth Day 2021
and the world premiere
of "Secrets of the Whales" on Disney+.
In a moment, singer-songwriter
Alt Bloom will tell you
how you can be part of Share Your Spot,
Nat Geo's Earth Day hashtag challenge.
So kickback and get ready
to celebrate our shared love
for the planet we all call home.
- [Alt Bloom] Where is your favorite spot?
That spot where our planet
feels most like home,
where you feel most alive,
most hopeful, most connected
to our world and others.
National Geographic wants you
to share your favorite spot
using #shareyourspot.
We may even share it
with our hundreds of
millions of followers,
a growing movement of
people who love our planet
as much as you do.
Join us and share your spot.
- Hi, I'm Aurora and I think
it's fantastic to be here
with you on National
Geographic Earth Day Eve.
I especially love being here
because the matter of nature
and the Earth is such an
important cause for me.
It lies so close to my heart.
For me, nature is definitely
the biggest source
of inspiration.
And it's the only place
I feel like I can go
where no one ever asks you of anything.
You can just purely exist out here
which I really, really love.
This forest is a forest
that means a lot to me.
I spent a lot of time here as a child,
and it's very nice to be back.
I feel very at home.
(soft guitar music)
♪ Just like the seed ♪
♪ I don't know where to go ♪
♪ Through dirt and shadow I grow ♪
♪ I'm reaching light
through the struggle ♪
♪ Just like the seed ♪
♪ I'm chasing the wonder ♪
♪ I unravel myself ♪
♪ In slow motion ♪
♪ Mm mm mm, mm mm mm ♪
(singers vocalizing)
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
♪ When the last tree has fallen ♪
♪ And the rivers are poisoned ♪
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
♪ When the last tree has fallen ♪
♪ And the rivers are poisoned ♪
♪ You cannot eat money oh, no ♪
♪ Mm mm, suffocate me ♪
♪ So my tears can be rain ♪
♪ I will water the ground where I stand ♪
♪ So the flowers can grow back again ♪
♪ 'Cause just like the seed ♪
♪ Everything wants to live ♪
♪ We are burning our fingers ♪
♪ But we learn and forget ♪
♪ Mm mm mm, mm mm mm ♪
(singers vocalizing)
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
♪ When the last tree has fallen ♪
♪ And the rivers are poisoned ♪
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
(singer vocalizing)
♪ When the last tree has fallen ♪
♪ And the rivers are poisoned ♪
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
♪ Oh no ♪
♪ Feed me sunlight, feed me air ♪
♪ Feed me truth and feed me prayer ♪
♪ Mm mm mm ♪
♪ Feed me truth and feed me prayers ♪
(Aurora vocalizing)
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
♪ When the last tree has fallen ♪
♪ And the rivers are poisoned ♪
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
(singer vocalizing)
♪ When the last tree has fallen ♪
♪ And the rivers are poisoned ♪
♪ You cannot eat money, oh no ♪
♪ Oh no ♪
(singers vocalizing)
- What a great way to start the night.
After this, I'll be grabbing my phone
to check out everyone's
happy places posted
with #shareyourspot.
So get on it.
Now, I'm standing in the
historic Hubbard Hall,
the original home
of the nonprofit National
Geographic Society.
For over 130 years, the
society has been investing
in bold people and transformative ideas,
including the two people
we're about to hear from.
Before that, here's more
about how the National
Geographic Society drives impact
by identifying
and funding an international
community of explorers.
- [Girl] If I was an Explorer.
- [Boy] I would wake up.
- [Girl] Put on my hijab.
- [Boy] Put on my gear.
- [Girl] I would take
my tools to investigate.
- [Boy] I'd put on my spacesuit.
- [Girl] Then I'd shoot
off into the stars.
- [Girl] If I was an explorer,
I wouldn't care about getting dirty.
- [Boy] I would take my
findings back to the lab-
- [Girl] To build things,
create new things.
- [Dominique] To be an explorer is
all about understanding this world better.
- [Hannah] To show the world
a different way of seeing.
- [Arthur] To venture into
unchartered territory.
My name is Arthur Huang.
- [Hannah] Hannah Reyes Morales.
- [Dominique] Dominique
d'Emille Correia Goncalves.
- [All] And this is what
an explorer looks like.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, everyone.
I'm Dr. Rae Wynn-Grant.
I'm a wildlife ecologist
and a National Geographic Explorer.
Thank you for joining me
and National Geographic
for this Earth Day Eve celebration.
I love Earth Day.
I feel like I celebrate it
every single time I go out
and do my work.
But on April 22nd, I always
love to connect with nature.
Whether it's a trail or a local park
or even going to the beach,
connecting with nature
on April 22nd is my way of
giving back and saying thanks.
Some work I've been doing
recently that I'm super proud of,
it's aiming to protect
female animals to make sure
that they have the healthy,
thriving habitats they need
in order to give birth.
Females create the next
generation of wild animals
for our planet,
and their health means
the health of the world.
Where's my spot?
Here is my spot.
- Hello, everyone.
My name is Lillygol Sedaghat,
and I'm a National Geographic Explorer
here in San Diego, California,
in my favorite place in the
whole wide world, the slab.
This place is really important to me.
It brings together people
and planet and place.
You've got the blue sky
and the beautiful golden sun,
big trees, the green grass,
and this concrete that allows
all of my friends and I
to come here every weekend
to be able to practice breakdancing.
Earth Day is about connectivity
and understanding that we're connected
to people and place and planet.
And this space represents that
to me in its fullest degree.
So I wanted to share it with you.
Join me and the Nat Geo family
for a celebration on Earth Day 2021.
Bye.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- Wonderful to hear from Rae,
and Lillygol, I see that breakdancing.
Is there a cooler job title
than National Geographic Explorer?
Right now, I'm super excited
to be among the first to step foot
in the National Geographic
Museum's brand new exhibition,
Once Upon a Climb, Stories from Everest
opening later this year.
The exhibit is the latest
in National Geographic's long history
of working on Mount Everest,
including awarding nearly 200 grants
for Everest-related projects.
In addition to being the
world's highest mountain,
Everest is also a massive water tower
that supplies drinking water
to over a billion people,
making its protection
all the more important.
But now, we travel from Nepal to Sweden
to link up with Jose Gonzales,
who'll be performing his
brand new track "Visions"
off his forthcoming album, "Local Valley."
Then we'll catch a performance from one
of the greatest artists
in world music today,
the legendary Angelique Kidjo.
- Hi, I'm Jose Gonzalez.
I'm happy to be here with
you on this Earth Day Eve.
I'm excited as a longtime fan
of National Geographic and
as a fan of our planet.
We're filming this at Saro Vasterskog
near my hometown Gothenburg
on the west coast of Sweden.
Since I was a kid, we
used to cycle to the ocean
to hang out with friends and family.
And I love it by the archipelago
with its granite rocks,
oaks and pine trees just by the water.
For the last couple of
years I've been writing
and recording close to
nature, taking walks
while listening to sketches
of my half-finished songs.
I have to say the forests and water
give me perspective and calm.
Suddenly I can pause
my ruminating thoughts
and feel at ease.
The song I'm going to
play is called "Visions."
It's a song for our humanity
and the Anthropocene.
We are the apes that are starting
to understand the universe
and our place in it.
We are changing our surroundings
at an exceedingly rapid pace,
so much that we're becoming
stewards of our planet,
whether we like it or not.
So we need visions,
visions of the future, collective visions
that are wise enough
to learn from our past
and from the present,
envisioning a future
where we all can flourish.
(soft guitar music)
♪ Visions ♪
♪ Trying to make sense of the now ♪
♪ Trying to make sense of the past ♪
♪ To show us how ♪
♪ Visions ♪
♪ Imagining the worlds that could be ♪
♪ Shaping a mosaic of fates ♪
♪ For all sentient beings ♪
♪ Visions ♪
♪ Cycles of growth and decay ♪
♪ Cascading chains of events ♪
♪ With no one to praise or blame ♪
♪ Mm ♪
♪ Visions ♪
♪ Avoidable suffering and pain ♪
♪ We are patiently inching our way ♪
♪ Toward unreachable utopias ♪
♪ Visions ♪
♪ Enslaved by the forces of nature ♪
♪ Elevated by mindless replicators ♪
♪ Challenged to steer
our collective destiny ♪
♪ Visions ♪
♪ Look at the magic of reality ♪
♪ While accepting with all honesty ♪
♪ That we can't know
for sure what's next ♪
♪ No we can't know for sure what's next ♪
♪ But that we're in this together ♪
♪ We are here together ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Mm ♪
♪ Oh, we are here together ♪
♪ We are here together ♪
- Hello everyone.
My name is Angelique Kidjo,
and I'm so happy to be
with National Geographic
to celebrate Earth Day evening.
This song "Dignity" is about
our dignity as human being
as we live on Earth that is carrying us,
that have carried us for generations.
And I think it's about time
that we pay attention
more to Mother Earth.
My continent is the one that
is really feeling the heat
and is feeling the pain
of this global change.
And I think that we, that's the
reason why I wrote this song
with Yemi Alade,
and I'm trying to bring the new generation
of musician to raise their
voice, to save our Earth.
And altogether, we can surely do this.
(upbeat music)
(Angelique singing in foreign language)
♪ Dignity, can save you or kill you ♪
♪ Dignity, I wanna hold on to you ♪
♪ Dignity, can hurt you or heal you ♪
♪ Were you there yesterday ♪
♪ When the gunman shoot men down ♪
♪ No retreat ♪
♪ No surrender ♪
♪ He can push you no fall down ♪
♪ Many come, many go ♪
♪ We're not asleep, we're there for all ♪
♪ We come in peace ♪
♪ Not in pieces ♪
♪ Oh yeah, yeah Oga ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal, is reciprocal ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal ♪
♪ My Oga, oh oh ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal, is reciprocal ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal ♪
(Angelique singing in foreign language)
♪ Where they disguise it ♪
♪ I don't tire, tire oh ♪
♪ As I look your eyes ♪
♪ Giant of Africa ♪
♪ When life be better ♪
♪ You promise me tomorrow ♪
♪ But nobody sees tomorrow ♪
♪ I don't tire, oh ♪
♪ Tire, tire ♪
♪ Tire for the lamba ♪
♪ I don't tire, oh tire, tire ♪
♪ Why the to they lie ♪
♪ I don't tire, oh, tire, tire ♪
♪ Tire for the lamba ♪
♪ Why the to they lie, my Oga ♪
♪ Oh, respect is
reciprocal, is reciprocal ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal ♪
♪ My Oga, oh oh ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal, is reciprocal ♪
♪ Respect is reciprocal ♪
♪ Were you there yesterday ♪
♪ When the gunman shoot men down ♪
♪ No retreat, no surrender ♪
♪ He can push you, no fall down ♪
♪ Many come, many go ♪
♪ We're not asleep, we're there for all ♪
♪ We come in peace ♪
♪ Not in pieces ♪
♪ Oh yeah, yeah ♪
♪ The glimpse of hope in humanity ♪
♪ The last frontier of our own sanity ♪
♪ Spread your love to all equally ♪
♪ And plant the seeds of radical beauty ♪
♪ The wind will blow ♪
♪ The light will show ♪
♪ Real Beauty on a brand new day ♪
♪ The wind will blow ♪
♪ The light will show ♪
♪ Real Beauty on a brand new day ♪
♪ It will glow on a brand new day ♪
♪ A clear way on a brand new day ♪
♪ We'll get down on a brand new day ♪
♪ Walk with your head straight ♪
♪ Reciprocal ♪
♪ Stand with your head straight ♪
♪ Walk with your head straight ♪
♪ Reciprocal ♪
♪ Stand with your head straight ♪
- Next up, the Berkshires,
an epic performance
from the incomparable Yo-Yo Ma awaits.
He is also featured in the May issue
of "National Geographic"
magazine now on newsstands.
But first, we're honored
to share a special message
from the ever-inspiring Dr. Jane Goodall.
- Hello, this is Jane
Goodall, and it's Earth Day.
So thank you for joining me on Earth Day.
It's a day when we should
be celebrating the wonder
of this amazing planet on which we live.
It's our only home, and we
still have so much to discover.
But the tragedy is that we've
been disrespecting nature
and this is causing climate change.
It's causing the loss of species,
the loss of biodiversities.
So we're in the sixth great extinction.
And so today on Earth
Day, we need to reflect
on the harm that we've done
and think about ways in
which we can work together
to heal that harm before it's too late.
And you know, just as an aside,
it was our disrespect
of nature and animals
that caused this terrible pandemic
that's led to so much
suffering around the world.
And you know, we created
conditions with trafficking animals
around the world, killing
them, eating them,
wildlife markets, factory farms.
In all these things,
we create conditions where a pathogen,
like a virus can jump
from an animal to a person
and sometimes create a new disease,
as was the case with COVID-19.
Bad luck for us that was very contagious
and just went racing around the world.
And we'll get through that,
but then we're faced
with two real threats,
climate change and loss of biodiversity.
And that also is caused by our disrespect
for both of these, by our
disrespect for nature.
So as I say on this Earth Day,
let's get together and
start thinking of ways
in which we can heal some of this harm.
What can you do?
What can I do?
I think first of all, we can make lists
of what we as individuals
can do to save the planet.
And that's something you
can all do, sit down,
discuss it with your
friends, your parents,
and make a list, but
not just for Earth Day.
We should look at this
list every single day,
because that's what it's going
to take to save the planet.
So the message really
is Earth Day every day.
Earth Day for planet Earth,
this beautiful planet that nurtures us,
this environment of which we are part
and on which we depend,
and we mustn't go on destroying it.
Partly because it's
beautiful in its own right,
partly because it's destroying
our great-grandchildren's future,
if we don't start healing it.
We're really using up some
natural resources faster
than nature can replenish them,
and as species become extinct,
so I like to think of it
as tearing holes in this
beautiful tapestry of life.
And as more and more
species become extinct,
so this tapestry becomes more
and more tattered and a
whole ecosystem can collapse.
So think of what you
can do as an individual.
I try to think every day
of my ecological footprint.
I try to turn off lights
and not waste water,
and well, in the pandemic,
I haven't been able to fly
or I haven't even driven anywhere.
So I think my footprint
has been especially light.
I'm not eating meat and trying
to keep away from dairy.
I've been pretty well vegan
while I've been at home
and sending out messages
all over the world
on Zooms and podcasts,
so that we encourage more and more people
to lead lives that are
friendly towards nature.
And that's what you can do.
And our Roots & Shoots program,
which is for young people
from preschool, university
and everything in between
and even some adults now,
these are exactly the kind of things
that they and other youth programs
with the same mission are doing.
So think about all of this on Earth Day.
Do your bit and together
we can save the planet.
Thank you. Goodbye.
- I'm so happy to join you
from the grounds of Tanglewood.
These Berkshire Hills
in western Massachusetts
have been a spiritual home for
many, a source of inspiration
for makers of music and poetry,
for builders of homes and
communities for millennia.
Look to the shores of the lake
in the distance, Lake Mackinac.
Mackinac, the home of the Mohicans,
the indigenous people of this place
who live now in upper Wisconsin
and are known as the
Stockbridge-Munsee Band
of Mohican Indians are the people
for whom the waters are never still.
They used to share music
on the shores of the lake,
and they still cherish this
land as hallowed ground.
Today, by combining the
human enterprise of music
with the majesty of nature,
we continue a sacred practice.
Through the ephemeral nature of music,
we are reminded that we are
but temporary custodians
of this land.
And it is our duty to cultivate
the land and ourselves
to find balance between humans and nature
as this place's indigenous
people teach us,
in order that our species
can survive and thrive.
So with gratitude, here
is this offering of music
for our Earth Day celebration.
(bright cello music)
- Such a moving performance from Yo-Yo Ma.
You can learn more about him
in Nat Geo's new book "Spark"
coming out April 27th from
bestselling author Claudia Kalb.
And does it get any better than Jane?
Coming up next,
We have a world premiere
video from My Morning Jacket,
as well as an appearance by
singer-songwriter Valerie June.
And stick around, still
coming up are performances
by Willie Nelson, Maggie
Rogers, and so much more.
- Hi, I'm Jim James
from My Morning Jacket,
and we are so grateful to be here with you
and National Geographic on Earth Day Eve
as we know now more than ever
it's so important for us all
to send as much love as we can
to Mother Earth
for her continued healing and protection.
Thank you.
♪ Are we undercover ♪
♪ What's left to see ♪
♪ Trying to discover ♪
♪ How it came to be ♪
♪ In a past life ♪
♪ Feeling loved ♪
♪ But now in the present ♪
♪ Seeing blood ♪
♪ And all I want to do is feel you ♪
♪ Feel you ♪
♪ Whoa, making time to
waste time to feel time ♪
♪ Oh, wash over you ♪
♪ Ooh, watching you, watching me ♪
♪ Reaching out between the worlds ♪
♪ To feel you, yeah ♪
♪ And all I want to do is feel you, yeah ♪
♪ Are we under covers raining blood ♪
♪ And all I want to do is feel you ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, and all I
want to do is feel you ♪
♪ Feel you ♪
♪ Oh, making time to
waste time to feel time ♪
♪ Oh, wash over you ♪
♪ Ooh, watching you watching me ♪
♪ Reaching out between the worlds ♪
♪ To feel you, yeah ♪
♪ And all I want to do is feel you, yeah ♪
- I'm Lucy Hawkes.
I'm a marine biologist and a
National Geographic Explorer,
and I'm here in Devon on
the south coast of England.
I'm passionate about
protecting the Earth around me,
because I study some of
the most amazing animals
that we share it with.
I study animal migration,
and I use tracking tags to
follow the incredible movements
of migratory species.
Because of my work, I've
been able to find out
that birds can make flights
of more than 1000 miles at a time
without needing to stop to
eat, to drink or to sleep.
Or that sea turtles in our
oceans can stay under water
for more than seven hours at a time.
And currently, I'm studying
a small angry white seabird
called the Arctic tern.
These birds weigh about
the same as a bar of soap,
but they can make a journey every year
from the Arctic to
Antarctica and back again
clocking enough distance
over the course of their life
to make six return trips
to the moon and back.
We're tracking them
using tiny little tracking tags like this,
and I can't tell you
what a privilege it is
as a scientist to be allowed
to hold this amazing bird in my hand,
to look at this tiny little creature
that sees the world at a planetary scale.
And the more I study these
animals, the more passionate I am
about protecting the Earth
around me and around you too.
Because every spring and
fall the skies above you
and the oceans around you are filled
with incredible migratory species
no matter where you live on Earth.
And I consider myself really
lucky to share the planet
with these animals.
So thank you for joining me
and the National Geographic
on this Earth Day Eve celebration.
- Hello there, I'm Valerie June.
I recorded my performance
for National Geographic at Prospect Park,
and I recorded a song
called "Home Inside."
It's a song to remind all of us
that Earth is a school,
and how we treat the Earth
and how we respect each other is super,
super important for the
healing of our planet.
As I wrote in my book,
Mother Earth is continuously
trying to communicate with us.
The environment is in
a state of emergency.
We're facing a climate crisis.
But miraculous things can happen
when we are living mindfully.
The smallest steps to respect the Earth
could positively shift the planet faster
than we could ever
dream would be possible.
I do believe that each citizen
of the planet has a responsibility
to respect the Earth,
to treat it kind,
and in doing so, love
and respect each other.
Enjoy the song.
♪ Hm, hm-hm-hm, hm-hm-hm-hm ♪
♪ I know there is a place for me ♪
♪ Help me to grow that I may leaving see ♪
♪ A stream that flows
so well no end to find ♪
♪ That holds the key and
stills my chattering mind ♪
♪ I know ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ There is a home inside ♪
♪ Window to soul where
every dream abides ♪
♪ Each breath is gold ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ A pathway light, a guide ♪
♪ Garden to grow, keep on the sunny side ♪
♪ Some call it prayer ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Some say it should not cease ♪
♪ Some sit and breathe ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Some fall on bended knees ♪
♪ I'd be a fool ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ To let it have a name ♪
♪ Earth is a school ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ To shine is why you came ♪
♪ Some call it prayer ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Some say it should not cease ♪
♪ I must agree ♪
♪ It's how I find my peace ♪
♪ I'd be a fool ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ To let it have a name ♪
♪ Earth is a school ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ To shine is why you came ♪
♪ I know there is a place for me ♪
♪ Help me to grow that I may leaving see ♪
♪ A stream that flows
so well no end to find ♪
♪ That holds the key and
stills my chattering mind ♪
- What a cool video from My Morning Jacket
and a stellar performance by Valerie June.
Also, great to hear from Lucy.
Next up, we've got National
Geographic Explorer
and photographer Brian Skerry
giving us a sneak peek at
"Secrets of the Whales,"
the epic four-part series
premiering on Disney+ on Earth Day.
- Hi, I'm Brian Skerry,
National Geographic
photographer and producer.
And thank you for joining me and Nat Geo
for this Earth Day Eve celebration.
You know, throughout all the years
that I've been exploring
the world's oceans,
I've seen so many beautiful things,
but I often see some pretty
bad things out there too.
Still, I remain hopeful
because I know the ocean has
the ability to heal itself
if we simply protect it.
I first learned about this while working
on a story in New Zealand
about marine-protected areas
and saw underwater
ecosystems that had rebounded
and were thriving because of conservation.
So the place that makes
me feel most hopeful
about the future of the planet
is the Poor Knights Island in New Zealand,
because it was there that I
first learned what was possible.
I think every day should be Earth Day,
because I've seen time and time again
just how extraordinary our planet is.
I remain passionate about our planet,
because whether you travel
to the ends of the Earth
or into your own backyard,
discoveries can be made.
And while Earth Day is
always a special day,
this year there's a special
reason to celebrate,
my three-year project
about whales culminates
with the Earth Day premiere
of the Disney+ original series
"Secrets of the Whales."
It's also the subject of my
new National Geographic book
of the same name, as well as a cover story
in the May issue of "National
Geographic" magazine.
I'm excited to share a clip
from the series with all of you
and hope you'll check it out on Disney+
starting at midnight.
(soft music)
- [Narrators] Whales are the world's
most intelligent giants,
but they're still a mystery.
(whales squeaking)
Only now are we beginning
to understand their secrets.
- [Man] Right there, right there.
(camera shutter clicking)
- [Narrator] Three years of filming
reveal an extraordinary truth.
Whales have culture.
(beluga chirping)
Each family speaks a unique language.
They love deeply,
play with joy
and mourn their dead.
Whales are just like us.
And one of the smartest
of them all is proving
that these social bonds are
the secret to their success.
- What amazing footage.
Don't forget, the Disney+ world premiere
of "Secrets of the Whales"
is just a few hours away.
For now, let's check out a fun performance
of "I Don't Want to Live on Mars"
by the one and only Ziggy Marley
before Rostam serenades us
with "These Kids We Knew."
- Hi, I'm Ziggy Marley,
and I'm very happy to be
here celebrating Earth Day
on this Earth Day Eve
with National Geographic.
Earth is my mother, there is no other.
So for me, so for all of you,
so coming together and giving some love,
show some appreciation and
highlighting the affection
and the importance of respecting the Earth
and choosing the earth
as a partner in our life
I think is very important,
and I'm very happy to be a part of it.
So thank you for having me.
Enjoy.
This one is called, "I
Don't Want to Live on Mars,"
and I wrote this especially
as a song dedicated to
love, my Earth, you know.
♪ I don't want to live on Mars ♪
♪ I don't want drive space cars ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you
and do the things we do ♪
♪ Don't wanna escape to the moon ♪
♪ Can't let the world go boom ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you ♪
♪ And do the right things to you ♪
♪ You give me everything I need ♪
♪ You're my garden, you're my breeze ♪
♪ Let me get down and thank you please ♪
♪ And let me lay here for a while ♪
♪ 'Cause your beauty makes me high ♪
♪ If you're smiling I will smile, yeah ♪
♪ And let me make one thing clear ♪
♪ Nothing can compare ♪
♪ Your love is the blue sky,
your love is a butterfly ♪
♪ I don't wanna live on Mars ♪
♪ I don't wanna drive space cars ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you
and do the things we do ♪
♪ Don't wanna escape to the moon ♪
♪ Can't let the world go boom ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you ♪
♪ And do the right things to you ♪
♪ Oh good karma you're my queen ♪
♪ Precious things my eyes have seen ♪
♪ The sweetest place they've ever been ♪
♪ You make me feel just like a king ♪
♪ I'll never leave you for that girl ♪
♪ Oh my darling you're my world, yeah ♪
♪ That witch called winter can be mean ♪
♪ Summers like I've never seen ♪
♪ They say I'm love crazy, love crazy ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't wanna live on Mars ♪
♪ I don't wanna drive space cars ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you,
let's do the things we do ♪
♪ Don't wanna escape to the moon ♪
♪ Even if the world whoa ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you ♪
♪ And do the right things to you ♪
♪ Can't take the heat,
turn down the fire, oh ♪
♪ Can't swim don't tempt the waters ♪
♪ Believe what you want ♪
♪ This is my right of view ♪
♪ I'm gonna be true, I got
to get through to you, oh ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't wanna live on Mars ♪
♪ I don't wanna drive space cars ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you
and do the things we do ♪
♪ Don't wanna escape to no moon ♪
♪ I can't let the world go boom ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you ♪
♪ And do the right things to you ♪
♪ I don't wanna live on Mars ♪
♪ I don't wanna drive space cars ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you,
let's do the things we do ♪
♪ Don't wanna escape to the moon ♪
♪ Yo, even if the no, no, no ♪
♪ I just wanna be with you ♪
♪ I'll do the right things to you ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't wanna live on Mars ♪
Love you, Mother Earth.
Blessed Mother Day.
(somber music)
- Hey, what's up?
This is Rostam.
It's so nice to be here with you all
and with National Geographic on Earth Day.
The song I'm gonna play for you is called
"These Kids We Knew."
I wrote it while I had COVID-19.
The problems that we have in
our world are interrelated.
The environment is something that we have
to all take care of.
And these interrelated
problems can't be solved
unless we solve all of them,
and it can't happen unless
we do it all together.
That's really how I feel about it
and hopefully some of that philosophy
made it into the song.
Thank you.
(upbeat rock music)
♪ These kids we knew for so long ♪
♪ They don't speak like
they've been spoken to ♪
♪ By governments or emperors ♪
♪ Gonna line you up on
the sidewalk court ♪
♪ Ain't proud of where we're going ♪
♪ You say we can't afford the slow down ♪
♪ But the skies won't take it no more ♪
♪ So we're gonna slowly pull
the Earth back together ♪
♪ These kids we knew for so long ♪
♪ They don't speak like
they've been spoken to ♪
♪ By governments or emperors ♪
♪ Gonna line you up on
the sidewalk court ♪
♪ Ain't proud of where we're going ♪
♪ You say we can't afford the slow down ♪
♪ But the skies won't take it no more ♪
♪ So we're gonna slowly pull
the Earth back together ♪
- Those were truly wonderful performances
from Ziggy and Rostam.
Earlier we heard from Jane Goodall
who once said, "Only if we
understand will we care.
"Only if we care will we help.
"Only if we help shall all be saved."
That mindset has been
at the core of Nat Geo's
purpose-driven storytelling.
And now they're taking
that one step further
through the creation of Planet Possible,
National Geographic's new
platform to inform, inspire
and empower consumers to live
more lightly on the planet.
Here's more about this
exciting new program.
And then we'll pay a visit
to Willie Nelson's backyard
for a performance of "Laws of Nature."
(soft music)
♪ Hurry, the mountains are calling ♪
♪ Dive in the lakes and the oceans ♪
♪ Follow the rivers ♪
♪ And forests around you ♪
♪ The wild is out there
pulling inside you ♪
♪ A feeling that can't be erased ♪
♪ I believe the impossible
is possible together ♪
♪ Yeah, I believe, oh ♪
♪ I believe, oh, eh ♪
- Hi, National Geographic.
I'm Willie Nelson, and this
is my song, "Laws of Nature."
(energetic guitar music)
♪ I get my energy from the sun ♪
♪ And I'm not the only one ♪
♪ And I feel better when I'm done ♪
♪ I get my energy from the sun ♪
♪ I get my oxygen from the air ♪
♪ Plenty for me and plenty to spare ♪
♪ And I can find it anywhere ♪
♪ I get my oxygen from the air ♪
♪ And I plant my seeds
in the howling gale ♪
♪ But the laws of nature still prevail ♪
♪ Look at them seeds and look at me ♪
♪ The apple didn't fall
far from the tree ♪
♪ And I get my water from the rain ♪
♪ And if it don't rain I'll die ♪
♪ Stormy weather saves my life ♪
♪ Sometimes I laugh and wonder why ♪
- We're getting closer and closer
to the world premiere of "Secrets
of the Whales" on Disney+.
One of the biggest threats to marine life
is single-use plastics.
So here I am in a dress
made from 79 recycled plastic bottles.
Isn't it the perfect Earth Day Eve outfit?
And now we'll close out the
program with Maggie Rogers
who will be delivering a
golden hour performance
of "Love You for a Long Time."
Before we go, don't forget
to share photos and videos
of your happy places using #shareyourspot
and come over to Nat Geo's TikTok next
for a very special after party.
Thank you so much for joining us.
We hope you feel excited and inspired
by everything you've seen and heard today.
Happy Earth Day from National Geographic.
- Hey, I'm Maggie Rogers
here with National
Geographic on Earth Day Eve.
We are in beautiful Topanga Canyon
in Los Angeles, California,
which I love for its wildness
and for its history of music.
I am joined tonight by
Sam Gendel and Sam Wilkes,
two of my favorite musicians
to play "Love You for a Long Time."
(soft piano music)
♪ Came in like a vision
from the old west wind ♪
♪ Like a bright new dream
that I was stepping in ♪
♪ I saw your face and
I knew it was a sign ♪
♪ And I still think about
that moment all of the time ♪
♪ You know that I could
never make this up ♪
♪ I found the reason and
I'm not giving it up ♪
♪ I felt the fever and
I knew he was mine ♪
♪ Oh and I am gonna love
you for a long time ♪
♪ And in the morning when I'm waking up ♪
♪ I swear that you're the first
thing that I'm thinking of ♪
♪ I feel it in my body,
know it in my mind ♪
♪ Oh I ♪
♪ I'm gonna love you for a long time ♪
♪ Oh, I never knew it, yeah,
you took me by surprise ♪
♪ While I was getting lost so
deep inside your diamond eyes ♪
♪ So many things that I still wanna say ♪
♪ And if devotion is a river,
then I'm floating away ♪
♪ And in the morning when you pick me up ♪
♪ And all the world is quiet,
'cept the mourning dove ♪
♪ I feel it in my body,
know it in my mind ♪
♪ Oh I ♪
♪ Oh, don't slow down now ♪
♪ Gonna break me down ♪
♪ Put your hands in my hair ♪
♪ Put your mouth on my mouth ♪
♪ Don't slow this down, never let me go ♪
♪ Baby, don't you wanna see
how far this thing can go ♪
♪ Can go, oh ♪
♪ Never letting go ♪
♪ Oh, and in the morning
when I'm waking up ♪
♪ I swear that forever
could never be enough ♪
♪ I feel it in my body,
know it in my mind ♪
♪ Oh I ♪
♪ Oh, I feel it in my
body, know it in my mind ♪
♪ Oh, I ♪
♪ Oh, I feel it in my
body, know it in my mind ♪
♪ Oh I ♪
♪ I'm gonna love you for a long time ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm gonna love you ♪
♪ Ooh, I'm gonna love you ♪